Theo số liệu mới công bố của các quan dịch Bộ Dí chúng nhất bản, tính đến quay tăng sống năm nay,
có 3 phải 5 triệu cơ dân nước ngoài đang sính sống tại thế này,
mất caong nhất từng được cái nhận, nhóm đường chúng nhận chiếm gần của chụng người,
trong khi số lỗi đồng có thịt thực ký sơ, chuyên dài, nhân văn và dịch của cú tế,
thang mạnh gần mùi phần chăm.
Sự rất thang này dễ dễ dễ dễ dễ dễ dễ bố càng nhìn bản đang phải đối mặt với tình trạng thiệu hủ lâu đồng,
đặc biệt trong các ngành sản xuất dịch bộ và chăm sóc suốt phay.
Chính vui nhé bản đang tự bước nối lòng của định nghiệp cơ,
đồng thời quyền khi xuân nghiệp tiếp nhận thêm lào đậm nước ngoài.
Sự thấy đổi cứ cầu dân cơ này được xem là bước ngoặc đối với định tình tế và sống hội nhé bản,
trong dịch bản giả ngoa dân xuống nhàng, dở chuyên giả chơ dàng,
lãn sống nước cơ này không chỉ giúp dưới trị tăng trưởng tình tế,
mặc còn làm thay đổi cầu chức sống hội nhé bản,
mặc có ra vốn nổi tiếng hết tính trong nhiều tập kỷ qua.